in terms of Rivals there are tiers the
first tier is like no Rivals and then a
little bit after that is Chicago he's
definitely the second after no Rivals Ms
Carlson looked for yet another win
against Hikaru Nakamura this time in the
AI cup just days ago Magnus defeated
Hikaru to win the speed Chess
Championship the first game of the match
was well contested until this mistake
Magnus quickly capitalized and won
hikara resides signed to everyone's
shock Hikaru offered Magnus a draw in
game two in the third and final game
Magnus launched an all-out attack on the
king side hikaru's position fell apart
in a move 38 Magnus made the brilliant
Knight takes D5 allowing Hikaru to
capture his rook in order to create a
serious Checkmate threat on hikaru's
King soon the game was won after the
match Agnes had this to say